[Music]
well we start here at six o'clock
continuing coverage that massive fire
many of you saw in the southwest Valley
believe it or not is still burning thank
you so much for being here this morning
yeah in addition to the smoke a lot of
you reported seeing Ash and on your cars
from miles away the fire started at
about 4 30 yesterday afternoon the
apartment building under construction
it's a big apartment building and it's
been burning ever since we have Team
coverage live for you this morning
Sherry we'll look at the weather
forecast how the winds played a factor
yesterday maybe not so much this morning
Lauren is live this morning near Buffalo
in 215 with the latest right now Lauren
good morning
hey good morning you guys yes that's
right still going strong out here the
fire is still burning from since about 4
30 yesterday over here near 2 15 and
buffalo now this was supposed to be a
614 residential unit building with some
retail space that's from True
development to the developers out here
but I'm joined Live Now by one of the
people that live nearby here April Kelly
good morning thank you for coming out
here hi hi so April you live over here
come a little closer here April real
quick
um you live over here you said a post
and rightly correct yes and so April you
guys were coming out of Walmart describe
to me what you guys saw what happened so
we were coming down uh four of Apache
and was uh getting ready to come over uh
Sunset and all of a sudden we just seen
this big dust of black clouds in the sky
and was wondering what was going on so
by the time we actually got up on the
overpass over to 15 on the other side we
could actually see the Flames coming
from over in this area it's like what is
that so we got closer and we was
actually literally right here behind you
over there we could actually fill the
heat from that fire it was intense and
this was really this is going on
construction since 2017. I mean now 12
hours later how it still looks what's
your reaction now I'm shocked I mean
this doesn't happen very often and maybe
I've lived here for 44 years and I think
the next biggest one we acquired we had
was the original MGM and this was really
bad I mean just to see the magnitude of
the fire that was like spread from here
to over there was like really huge I
think so much April for your time thank
you well we're going to keep keep it
here you know the update as they come in
again the fire the cause of the fire is
still under investigation live out here
near Buffalo and 215 Lauren to ready 8
news now I'm just so glad there were no
injuries Lauren that was great yeah
April talking about feeling the fire
there this though not the first time
that we've seen a construction fire in
that part of the valley we captured this
fire two years ago near Tropicana and
Fort Apache the complex was still being
built investigators later discovered the
fire was intentionally set it caused
more than 30 million dollars in Damages
and two weeks prior another condo
complex fires several units there burned
near tinea and Sky Point some of them a
total loss